et bien bonjour les amis nous sommes au
japon actuellement à kyoto avec un
bigorneau qu'est ce qu'on fait au japon
les amis c'est assez fou on est venu ici
pour sept jours et en fait on va aller
simplement voir un potentiel chien que
je vais adopter en fin d'année paraît
que je revienne au japon le chercher
dans un mois si c'est le bon on le voit
demain on a décidé d'adopter truies bébé
depuis le temps que tu attends c'est
beau chien alors pourquoi je vais
jusqu'au japon pour adopter un chien la
question est très légitime parce que je
vais adopter un chiba il nous a chez
nous c'est une race de chien japonaise
et a beaucoup d'élevages en france mais
j'ai pas hyper confiance bref j'ai vécu
des expériences qui font que j'ai pas
confiance à 100% et je me disais quitte
à avoir un chien japonais pourquoi ne
pas l'adopter dans son pays d'origine à
savoir directement au japon je suis
passé par un organisme qui a cherché
dans des élevages au japon pour moi un
truc hyper sérieux hyper clean
ils ont trouvé un élevage j'ai reçu
plein de vidéos là ces quatre dernières
semaines je bavais littéralement devant
vous avez maintenant autant at que nous
en attendant aujourd'hui je vais te
faire visiter un peu kyoto ouais on va
aller sur les traces de ce que j'ai fait
avec mon frère et mon père on va boire
du sac et nos pasteurisé anecdote quand
on avait bu un verre chacun de sackey et
ensuite on aller dans un magasin à côté
on a chacun acheter une montre donc
tenté d'acheter une montre allez c'est
parti pour visiter kyoto bon je voulais
qu'on aille voir le sac et non
pasteurisé au marché mais j'ai oublié
que ici au japon il est 9h30 du matin
déjà quand on boit à 13 heures tu finis
tu achètes une montre d'envoi hanover
mec tu achète une maison ici on verra
tension du coup on s'est rabattu sur un
magasin extrêmement cool qui s'appelle
masterpiece celle d'autres magasins nike
et htc avec extrêmement cool et maxence
a besoin d'un sac donc ça tombe plutôt
bien corrélation chance est que ce qu'il
faut savoir que ce sac depuis le collège
mais c'est totalement ridicule
maintenant dans sa quête nous j'allais
pas consommer 15 02 chf et du parachute
et larmes et du coup en fait c'est le
seul sac dans lequel je peux en
recommandant dit de vous que vous
trouverez tout le temps avec et du coup
ce qu'on peut dire que la problématique
de ce blog et ses dires il faudra 5 à
maxence et ça on est au japon juste pour
ça on est d'une dizaine de jours
[Musique]
on vient de sortir de la boutique ma
victoire tu peux monter tout nouveau sac
s'te plaît mais maintenant c'est pas
grave
non je ne suis en rien il est super cela
il contient ce que moi j'ai pu acheter
- est-ce que tu es d'accord pour dire
que c'est l'une des boutiques plus
stylée que t'es fais de ta vie c'est
vraiment trop bien à l'ambiance est
super les vendeurs sont trop cool on a
pu danser en toute liberté
mon mac sans cesse que c'est lors du sac
et non pasteurisé pas de me dire
[Musique]
les amis nous venons d'arriver devant
les shops que je vais faire goûter à
maxence c'est ceci c'est du sac et non
pasteurisé c'est à dire qu'il est non
pasteurisé donc pas pas leur année dans
notre pays puisqu'il doit être maintenue
au froid c'est le sac et qu'on peut voir
que ici au japon
c'est vrai ouais je suis pas trop pour
l'alcool non plus mais je trouve ça
vraiment un aspect culturel derrière je
mens le jeu et la mamounia l'épave ou
bien alors là on voit juste pour bouter
et peut découvrir un alcool veulent
manger le poisson à la dette inquiète
pas
[Musique]
c'est pas le plus mauvais que j'ai goûté
ce vin avec mon père m'en faire on avait
visité le pavillon d'or et avec lui on
va visiter le pavillon d'argent qui
apparemment est mieux que le pavillon
d'or en fait max ans vient d'en reverser
la moitié de son verre oui je crois
qu'il est un peu ilham motivé ça va les
pierres je crois qu'il est un peu
pompette nous sommes deux pavillons
d'argent en japonais guînes kakudji tu
fumes mais pas tf1 on voit pas de
téléphone ok tout comme au pavillon d'or
il ya un endroit où j'étais une pièce et
faire un vrai faux pas visé dans un
petit bocal
comment pavillon d'or il faut vider sur
cette pierre juste ici je fais le voeu
le parti ok donc le pavillon d'argent il
a été construit par le schéma sort est
en fait c'est le grand-père de yoshi
massa qui s'appelle yoshimitsu qui avait
construit le pavillon d'or le shogun
yoshimasa il a fait pour rivaliser avec
son grand-père est à la base il devait
être couverts de feuilles d'argent
le fait est qu'ils aient eu la guerre et
que du coup ça n'a pas abouti ce projet
et que du coup c'est le pavillon de base
dit dirk a ni or ni argent ni une
architecture typique japonaise
traditionnelle sans feuilles d'or qui
recouvre les trucs c'est ça c'est pour
ça que japonais en plus tendance à
préférer celui-là qui a préféré celui
qui est couvert de feuilles d'or
[Musique]
ce parti pour dormir demain on va voir
matsu c'est la première fois de ma vie
que je rencontre mon futur chien j'ai
trop hâte de le voir en vrai d'interagir
avec lui en vrai en fait on se retrouve
demain pour le sujet principal de cette
vidéo et un demain
[Musique]
et bien bonjour les amis j'espère que la
nuit était bonne pour vous pour nous
elle était très court je viens d'arriver
à fukui
fukui là on attend finalement la
personne de l'organisme par lequel je
passe pour adopter un chien au japon
elle va pas tarder à arriver elle serait
accompagnée d'une amie à moi japonaise
locale qui m'avait invitée au japon même
un ont donné en gros je parle anglais
avec elle elle traduit en japonais pour
l'organisme qui gère chien bref et
appliquées à temps est-ce qu'on n'a pas
trop hâte de voir il est
les amis on vient d'arriver et il ya une
cage en plein milieu avec nate sous la
dent c'est fou mais que j'ai trouvé de
sortir
moi
ses frères et soeurs ont déjà été
adoptées par des japonais
du coup il est tout seul maintenant
de centre-droit
noah chi de moto
il
jlb c'est ouf mais je trouve il est trop
mignon
elle est en fait la suite du programme
ses quatre chambres balle récupérée et
voilà en fait je peux pas les ramener en
france avant fin octobre parce qu'il ya
des lois en france devrait être et un
vaccin à faire trop attendre qu'il ait
trois mois et moi je pourrai récupérer
fin octobre il sera il commettra déjà
des petits tours histoire a déjà il
traduit habitués à la ville surtout au
bruit avoir des enfants d'autres animaux
désastre est importante pour un chien on
va le ramener dans l'avion là on va
prendre l'avion avec lui on va le
ramener à tokyo
les amis je vous présente taulard c'est
le père donat dessous il a huit ans et
il en pleine mue en fait c'est des
chiens qu'il me regarde et il en train
de perdre ses poils
[Musique]
heiva nui
il volait
je vous présente la maman de mathilde
[Musique]
bien
c'est le moment de le ramener on va
prendre l'avion jusqu'à tokyo il est sur
mes genoux et j'ai un drap score faible
c'est la première fois de sa vie durant
la voiture est habituellement un chien
quand on prend la voiture propre fois de
sa vie il vomit donc il va sûrement
vomir servait à l'élite
j'ai peur qu'ils se mettent à crier ou à
pleurer le pont qui quitte sa famille
l'art il a dû revoir à son père à sa
maman c'est triste début d'une nouvelle
vie pour toi mon nom est pour moi aussi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et voilà les amis c'est la fin de cette
vidéo avec natsu pourquoi ça se termine
maintenant parce qu'en fait à partir du
moment où j'ai mis les pieds à tokyo
avec natsuki je n'ai plus rien filmé
voilà j'ai fait que de profiter avec lui
pendant les cinq jours où je pouvais le
voir alors je peux vous montrer quelques
vidéos prises avec mon téléphone en
vertical au dégueulasse le premier jour
je suis allée me balader avec lui dans
le quartier de harajuku qui était juste
à côté de mon hôtel
même si ce détail est inutile alors
j'étais étonné de voir à quel point les
japonais sont fans des chiba vraiment
ils s'arrêtent ils veulent le car et
c'est bon ils te demandent à voir bien
évidemment je dire en france quand tu
balaton chien tout le monde s'en bat les
couilles
il a fait ses premiers pas dans une
ville avec beaucoup de bruit et beaucoup
de gens autour mais là plutôt bien réagi
donc c'est très bon signe et le
troisième jour je suis allé à yokohama
et là c'est un espace rempli de park il
à gambader dans l'air ça lui a rappelé
je pense l'élevage d'où il venait
il était hyper content je l'avais jamais
vu autant courir autant se dépenser pour
du coup il a dormi ensuite pendant une
heure dans l'herbe mais il était quand
même heureux en maître dans son sommeil
c'était la dernière journée que je
pouvais passer avec lui c'était la
meilleure de tout nous est pas rêver
mieux comme dernière journée et puis
là-bas j'en suis au même stade que vous
j'attends de pouvoir leur voire tout
simplement merci d'avoir gardé ce petit
blog j'espère qu'il vous aura plu
j'essaie de partager cette rencontre
avec vous du mieux que je pouvais même
si sur la fin j'étais égoïste en eux
rien finalement j'ai vraiment profité
c'est l'important je voulais pas partir
en ayant des regrets voilà n'hésitez pas
à passer à voir aussi la chaîne de
maxence qui m'a beaucoup aidé avec
macadré tout simplement pendant ce
voyage
à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo
portez vous bien et plein d'amour
[Musique]